let's go a bit into a background of why
you
started the diet so what were you
suffering with give me a brief
history of your health issues i suffered
from
chronic severe depression anxiety and
insomnia for over 40 years of my life
and
i i heard your dad say that he
eliminated his symptoms
you had eliminated jurors and i was
going to try it one way or another
because i had great belief in what you
all were offering
and you all were telling the truth
because it's work i started because i
had
debilitating mental illness bipolar
disorder
that turned into rapid cycling which
bipolar can be you know you have a good
couple of years and then you have some
bad years you can have
good months and then bad months mine
went into every single day i didn't know
who i was going to be
it was like i was two different people
and either i was up and able to function
or i was
in bed and completely unable to function
and so
i learned through you know researching
the carnivore diet that there was a
possibility
that other people had resolved their
bipolar disorder
symptoms with eating only meat and so
i just jumped right in i was so
miserable
yeah so i was always a pretty heavy set
kid
mine did start it was a little bit of
health and a little bit of
weight issues but i was always just
heavyset
i had a very skinny brother and a mom
with a
bombshell gorgeous figure and my dad
was always fairly overweight and growing
up i constantly heard
oh she looks like her daddy and i wanted
so much to look like my mom my gorgeous
mom
and feature-wise i did but i was just i
was just a big girl
i've been malnourished since sixth grade
was the first sign of malnourishment
when i was
diagnosed with osteoporosis came down i
had
very severe mood disorders in seventh
grade i was constantly getting sick
failure to thrive
i was diagnosed with multiple doctors
with failure to thrive which is really
alarming
and in seventh grade i had narcolepsy
adhd ocd insomnia
depression and i wasn't just diagnosed
with these i was
seriously suffering and i was
misdiagnosed with an eating disorder
more times than i can count even by my
functional medicine doctors
you